CH: To what extent is what happened, though,
in part, just an unintended consequence,
that the traditional media that you worked in
had this curation-mediation role,
where certain norms were observed,
certain stories would be rejected because they weren't credible,
but now that the standard for publication and for amplification
is just interest, attention, excitement, click,
"Did it get clicked on?"
"Send it out there!"
and that's what's -- is that part of what's caused the problem?
CA: I think it's a big problem, and we saw this in the election of 2016,
where the idea of "clickbait" was very sexy and very attractive,
and so all these fake news sites and fake news items
were not just haphazardly and by happenstance being put out there,
there's been a whole industry in the creation of fake news
in parts of Eastern Europe, wherever,
and you know, it's planted in real space and in cyberspace.
So I think that, also,
the ability of our technology to proliferate this stuff
at the speed of sound or light, just about --
we've never faced that before.
And we've never faced such a massive amount of information
which is not curated
by those whose profession leads them to abide by the truth,
to fact-check
and to maintain a code of conduct and a code of professional ethics.
CH: Many people here may know people who work at Facebook
or Twitter and Google and so on.
They all seem like great people with good intention --
let's assume that.
If you could speak with the leaders of those companies,
what would you say to them?
CA: Well, you know what --
I'm sure they are incredibly well-intentioned,
and they certainly developed an unbelievable, game-changing system,
where everybody's connected on this thing called Facebook.
And they've created a massive economy for themselves
and an amazing amount of income.
I would just say,
"Guys, you know, it's time to wake up and smell the coffee
and look at what's happening to us right now."
Mark Zuckerberg wants to create a global community.
I want to know: What is that global community going to look like?
I want to know where the codes of conduct actually are.
Mark Zuckerberg said --
and I don't blame him, he probably believed this --
that it was crazy to think
that the Russians or anybody else could be tinkering and messing around
with this avenue.
And what have we just learned in the last few weeks?
That, actually, there has been a major problem in that regard,
and now they're having to investigate it and figure it out.
Yes, they're trying to do what they can now
to prevent the rise of fake news,
but, you know,
it went pretty unrestricted for a long, long time.
So I guess I would say, you know,
you guys are brilliant at technology;
let's figure out another algorithm.
Can we not?
CH: An algorithm that includes journalistic investigation --
CA: I don't really know how they do it, but somehow, you know --
filter out the crap!
(Laughter)
And not just the unintentional --
(Applause)
but the deliberate lies that are planted
by people who've been doing this as a matter of warfare
for decades.
The Soviets, the Russians --
they are the masters of war by other means, of hybrid warfare.
And this is a --
this is what they've decided to do.
It worked in the United States,
it didn't work in France,
it hasn't worked in Germany.
During the elections there, where they've tried to interfere,
the president of France right now, Emmanuel Macron,
took a very tough stand and confronted it head on,
as did Angela Merkel.
CH: There's some hope to be had from some of this, isn't there?
That the world learns.
We get fooled once,
maybe we get fooled again,
but maybe not the third time.
Is that true?
CA: I mean, let's hope.
But I think in this regard that so much of it is also about technology,
that the technology has to also be given some kind of moral compass.
I know I'm talking nonsense, but you know what I mean.
CH: We need a filter-the-crap algorithm with a moral compass --
CA: There you go.
CH: I think that's good.
CA: No -- "moral technology."
We all have moral compasses -- moral technology.
CH: I think that's a great challenge. CA: You know what I mean.
CH: Talk just a minute about leadership.
You've had a chance to speak with so many people across the world.
I think for some of us --
I speak for myself, I don't know if others feel this --
there's kind of been a disappointment of:
Where are the leaders?
So many of us have been disappointed --
Aung San Suu Kyi, what's happened recently,
it's like, "No! Another one bites the dust."
You know, it's heartbreaking.
(Laughter)
Who have you met
who you have been impressed by, inspired by?
CA: Well, you talk about the world in crisis,
which is absolutely true,
and those of us who spend our whole lives immersed in this crisis --
I mean, we're all on the verge of a nervous breakdown.
So it's pretty stressful right now.
And you're right --
there is this perceived and actual vacuum of leadership,
and it's not me saying it, I ask all these --
whoever I'm talking to, I ask about leadership.
I was speaking to the outgoing president of Liberia today,
[Ellen Johnson Sirleaf,]
who --
(Applause)
in three weeks' time,
will be one of the very rare heads of an African country
who actually abides by the constitution
and gives up power after her prescribed term.
She has said she wants to do that as a lesson.
But when I asked her about leadership,
and I gave a quick-fire round of certain names,
I presented her with the name of the new French president,
Emmanuel Macron.
And she said --
I said, "So what do you think when I say his name?"
And she said,
"Shaping up potentially to be
a leader to fill our current leadership vacuum."
I thought that was really interesting.
Yesterday, I happened to have an interview with him.
I'm very proud to say,
I got his first international interview. It was great. It was yesterday.
And I was really impressed.
I don't know whether I should be saying that in an open forum,
but I was really impressed.
(Laughter)
And it could be just because it was his first interview,
but -- I asked questions, and you know what?
He answered them!
(Laughter)
(Applause)
There was no spin,
there was no wiggle and waggle,
there was no spend-five-minutes- to-come-back-to-the-point.
I didn't have to keep interrupting,
which I've become rather renowned for doing,
because I want people to answer the question.
And he answered me,
and it was pretty interesting.
And he said --
CH: Tell me what he said.
CA: No, no, you go ahead.
CH: You're the interrupter, I'm the listener.
CA: No, no, go ahead.
CH: What'd he say?
CA: OK. You've talked about nationalism and tribalism here today.
I asked him, "How did you have the guts to confront the prevailing winds
of anti-globalization, nationalism, populism
when you can see what happened in Brexit,
when you could see what happened in the United States
and what might have happened in many European elections
at the beginning of 2017?"
And he said,
"For me, nationalism means war.
We have seen it before,
we have lived through it before on my continent,
and I am very clear about that."
So he was not going to, just for political expediency,
embrace the, kind of, lowest common denominator
that had been embraced in other political elections.
And he stood against Marine Le Pen, who is a very dangerous woman.
CH: Last question for you, Christiane.
TED is about ideas worth spreading.
If you could plant one idea into the minds of everyone here,
what would that be?
CA: I would say really be careful where you get your information from;
really take responsibility for what you read, listen to and watch;
make sure that you go to the trusted brands to get your main information,
no matter whether you have a wide, eclectic intake,
really stick with the brand names that you know,
because in this world right now, at this moment right now,
our crises, our challenges, our problems are so severe,
that unless we are all engaged as global citizens
who appreciate the truth,
who understand science, empirical evidence and facts,
then we are just simply going to be wandering along
to a potential catastrophe.
So I would say, the truth,
and then I would come back to Emmanuel Macron
and talk about love.
I would say that there's not enough love going around.
And I asked him to tell me about love.
I said, "You know, your marriage is the subject of global obsession."
(Laughter)
"Can you tell me about love?
What does it mean to you?"
I've never asked a president or an elected leader about love.
I thought I'd try it.
And he said -- you know, he actually answered it.
And he said, "I love my wife, she is part of me,
we've been together for decades."
But here's where it really counted,
what really stuck with me.
He said,
"It is so important for me to have somebody at home
who tells me the truth."
So you see, I brought it home. It's all about the truth.
(Laughter)
CH: So there you go. Truth and love. Ideas worth spreading.
Christiane Amanpour, thank you so much. That was great.
(Applause)
CA: Thank you. CH: That was really lovely.
CA: Thank you.